BRIAN DORSEY: Hello, everyone.
My name is Brian.
I work on Google
Cloud, and we're
going to talk about where
should I run my code,
deciding between
all these pieces.
So I'm curious, how many
people here write code?
They OK.
Lots of hands.
This is what?
Maybe 80%?
How many people keep
systems running?
OK.
Another maybe 30%, 40%.
And how many people
tell other people
what to do, coordinate
work, that kind of thing?
OK.
Another 20%, 30%.
So lots of people here
do multiple things.
Thank you for coming.
And I think this will be
useful to all of those roles.
So developer operations,
managers, altogether.
So this question, where
should I run my code?
And the answer is, of
course, it depends.
And so this talk will talk
about all the different ways
that it depends.
At Google Cloud, we have
a lot of blue hexagons.
You've seen a lot of
blue hexagons today.
We're going to talk
mostly about these four,
and I'm going to kind of
start from the bottom up.
So Compute Engine are
our virtual machines.
Container Engine is
hosted Kubernetes, so
orchestration for containers.
App Engine is our
platform as a service.
Give us code, we'll run it.
And Cloud Functions are
kind of that internet glue.
You just give a function
definition and it runs.
So I'm going to make
a claim that you
can use each of these things
for many different things.
There's overlapping things.
But there's a sweet spot,
kind of the best, happy
spot for each of these.
And I claim that Compute
Engine is an excellent fit
for any existing system.
So you've got a large
complicated system that
runs a lot of different pieces.
It's probably running on virtual
machines or on hardware today,
and you can move that
over pretty much directly.
If you have a system
that is containers first,
like you've got all Docker
images and your setup
good to go and you
have a lot of those
you want to keep track of them,
Container Engine Kubernetes
is going to be a really
good fit for that.
If your application is primarily
web, HTTP request response,
App Engine is an excellent fit.
And if you're trying to respond
to events, asynchronous events,
and you just don't want
to think about the rest,
Cloud Functions is awesome.
So this is the claim
I'm going to make.
And we're going to go,
like I said, bottom up.
So VMs, containers,
paths, functions, and then
actually answer the
question, seriously,
where should I run my code?
And then we're going to
have Elie from LumApps
come up and talk
about their decision
and how they decided between
these before they existed.
So start off with
Compute Engine.
And Compute Engine is
our virtual machines,
infrastructure as a service.
It is compute, network, disk.
We have all sorts of specifics.
The machines can get
quite large, 96 GPUs--
sorry, 96 CPUs, eight GPUs,
lots of RAM, lots of disk.
And you can make a VM with each
of these almost independent.
So you can have a machine
with very large memory
and relatively small
CPU if that's what
you need for your application.
They start very quickly,
about 30 seconds,
and we have lots of base
images already that you
can use to use the
operating system that you
are most familiar with, and then
you can make your own images
from those.
I wanted to talk about
the disk a little bit.
So these are virtual machines.
We all know how
virtual machines work.
Except, in the cloud, things
can work a little differently.
So the disk, for example,
this, bigger disks
are faster in the sense
of more throughput.
So if you're doing
any kind of testing--
like perf testing,
you want to see
what's going to be fast, is
this fast enough for you--
larger disks are actually
higher throughput
because you're
getting a slice of all
of these different disks
in the data center,
and a bigger disk gives
you a bigger slice.
So you actually have more
physical disks working for you
the larger the disk is.
So that's maybe not obvious.
And it's more than just VMs.
So we have an optimized
OS that you can
use to just run one container.
So if you want to
run a Docker image,
you can boot up a VM that's
set up for doing that.
We have this system called
managed instance groups.
So instead of thinking
about one computer,
you can think about a pool
of identical computers.
And when you do
that, each of them
is created from
the same template,
and so you can make that
pool bigger or smaller.
And you just have
a dial for, I'd
like more computers doing
this processing or fewer.
And that allows autoscaling.
So you can hook that up
to traffic or CPQ metrics
and have it scale
the pool via those.
Or, use that to spread
it across multiple zones.
So if one zone goes
down, you still
have the same number of
computers running because it
will scale up in another zone.
And you can use it
for rolling updates.
If you have a new
version of the template,
you can actually drop one
machine off, add another one,
drop another one off,
add another new one,
and use that to kind of roll
to a new version of your base
image that you're using.
And then, our load
balancer, when
you use Compute Engine or
Container Engine, App Engine
all the way up,
the load balancer
is actually configuring
Google's data centers.
So you're using the
same load balancer
we use for YouTube and
for Maps and the like.
So you get to
configure it and go.
It's pretty fun.
So when you're
using this, you are
thinking about your software.
You're thinking about
the operating system
you want to run, how much
memory, network, disk you need,
and the networking rules-- how
the pieces talk to each other.
All of that is things
you need to consider.
And it's the things you're
used to thinking about in IT.
And there's APIs
for all of this.
It is a particularly
good fit when
you have an existing system.
You're going to kind of lift
something up and shift it
to another place.
This container-optimized
VM if you
want to just run one image, one
Docker image, it's very handy.
If you need a very specific
kernel or very specific
operating system, you may
have license requirements
that push you--
like you're only
allowed to run, say,
four CPUs for the licensing
i the same machine.
So you can use that.
It's handy for running
databases and if you need very
specific network protocols.
We'll see some of the other
options only run HTTP, HTTPS.
Each of the VMs starts
in about 30 seconds,
so it sets your kind of scaling.
You can run thousands of VMs
in like a minute to two minutes
time frame.
And it's up to you to decide
how you update your software,
update your OS,
security patches.
All of that work is
still in your world.
You have direct control
and responsibility
for managing that.
So demo.
Too much talking.
Let's go and try something out.
So this-- yay, this is
Google Cloud Platform.
Is relatively new?
You haven't done too
much look at the website?
How many people?
OK.
Maybe this won't be so exciting.
But the secret to
Google Cloud Platform
is this hamburger button.
Everything is in the
hamburger button.
That's where all of the
different features of Google
Cloud are.
And we will look at
the Compute Engine.
When I actually have some
things set up for later demos
and we can create
a new instance,
I'm going to pick a nearby
European data center.
And we can, of course, choose
from some kind of setup,
preconfigured, sized machines.
Or-- sorry, wrong link--
click Customize,
and we get a slider
for how many CPU
cores do you want,
how much memory do you want.
We can max them all
the way up, but I
have a specific size in mind.
It's kind of what I think
of as maybe the answer.
So that's the machine
we're going to build here.
And also, this is
where you would
set if you wanted to
run GPUs and the like.
You can choose the
basic operating system.
I'm just going to
go ahead and use
one of the premade
Debian machines we have,
but you can also kind of
pick from this whole list
of different images,
including Windows, SUSE,
Red Hat, and the like.
So we'll hit Create.
When I hit Create there, it's
actually made an HTTP request
off to the backend, and
it's allocating a new part
of a set of hardware somewhere.
It's connecting this disk
image to the machine,
booting the machine up.
And then, if I had
set it up, it could
start to run my code
once it comes up.
Oh, hey, good.
In demo fashion, it
finished quickly.
And I just wanted to show
you this button here.
This is the SSH button.
And what this does is, since I'm
logged in to the web interface,
I have already done an
OAuth authentication.
Google knows who
I am, and it will
push SSH keys to the instance
so that we can log in over SSH.
And you can do this from the
command line or from the web.
And it's a real computer.
We can prove that
it's a real computer
because we have scrolling text.
Thank you for laughing at that.
But basically, you can
SSH right from the web.
So that's like a really
quick tour of Compute Engine.
So why might you
choose Compute Engine?
Consistency.
If you do a test with
10 VMs, next week
you should see the same
behavior, the same performance
with 10 VMs, or in another
region the same behavior.
You can choose exactly
the shape of VM,
and this is really handy
for existing systems.
Instead of trying
to optimize or get
a bunch of different
pieces of software
to work on the same
machine because it happens
to have 128 gigs of RAM,
you can give one machine
32 and the other
96 and just keep
them separate with exactly how
much they need to be happy.
I will guess that
everyone in here
has had a computer
run out of disk
and fail at some
point in their life.
You can actually resize disks
that are attached to VMs
and make them larger and
then update the partition.
In most OSs, update all
the way through the OS
so it sees the additional
space and actually give it
space while it's
alive, which is fun.
And then our billing is set
up to be as easy as possible
to reason about, to understand,
automatically give you
discounts when you use it
over time, that sort of thing.
We also move these VMs.
If we have planned updates
to the hardware or the host
operating systems, we'll
actually move the VMs
to another machine.
And it's almost
unnoticeable, usually
in the single-digit
millisecond pause.
All the network traffic makes
it through, comes back up,
it's actually on new
hardware, and we continue on.
And it's a really natural fit
for many existing systems.
So Compute Engine, it's awesome.
And if you're using Container
Engine or App Engine Flex,
all of those are
actually running--
we use Compute Engine as the
base for running these as well.
So all of the benefits
I talked about so far,
you get in these
other tools as well.
So next, kind of we're
going to keep going.
Container Engine.
More questions.
How many people are using
containers, Docker, something
like that already?
OK.
That's maybe 40%,
50% of the room.
That's awesome.
And I'm going to just assume
everybody else is interested,
and so we're all in.
So the short version
of containers, why?
It solves the, well, it
worked on my machine,
why doesn't it work in
production problem very nicely.
It also gives you
a nice isolation
between different processes
so they can't hurt each other.
So they have all
their dependencies,
and they're kind of
insulated from each other.
And this enables all
sorts of good things
that you're probably aware of.
Once you decide you're
all in on containers,
then you could end up
with hundreds or thousands
of containers, and that's
where Kubernetes comes in.
And it is an open-source
orchestration system
for managing lots of containers.
It lets you treat a cluster
of machines as one thing.
And you say, run this
for me, and the cluster
figures out where to put it.
And if one of them goes
down, it figures out
where to start a new one.
So it keeps things set up
the way you want it to be.
It's open source,
owned by foundation.
Just a few days ago,
Docker announced
that they are
including Kubernetes
in their distribution
in the future.
It is really worth looking at.
So when you're using Kubernetes,
what do you think about?
Your thinking about
your application.
When you get into a meeting
room with your colleagues,
you've got a white
board, and you're
drawing lines and boxes
between the different parts
of the system.
And Kubernetes actually
lets you reason
about your system in a very
similar level of abstraction.
When you're making
a config file,
you say, this component, I
want five of them running.
And it uses this
other piece by name,
and Kubernetes figures out how
to connect them to each other,
how to do the networking.
So you get to live at this kind
of white-board level thinking
and push the configuration
down to the computers
at that level of abstraction.
So that's really powerful.
Container Engine is Google
Cloud's hosted version
of Kubernetes.
So we run the cluster for you.
We upgrade, keep the
nodes up to date,
update to new
versions of the host,
and scale the size of the
cluster for you up and down.
It's a very good fit
for any situation
where you need to insulate
yourself from the environment.
So you want to run the
same application, say,
on your own machines
or in a cloud,
in another cloud
in China and you
need it to work the same way.
It's also very useful to
have consistent behavior
through dev, test,
production, and basically
get high utilization
out of your systems
because you can have more
code running on them.
It's a really good
fit when you know
you're going to use
lots of containers,
so you can take full
advantage of them
and the ephemeral nature.
I'm going to say
it's a good fit for,
but this is also kind
of a requirement,
of needing good
team communication.
So between your dev, your
ops, and your security teams,
because the code is
deployed in these images,
if you want to make a
security fix to that code,
you need to be in
the same pipeline
that the developers are using.
Make the changes in
a compatible way.
So probably, you want a
continuous integration system
of some kind, a
build system, and you
want good communication
between the different parts
of your organization.
It requires you
to use containers.
So it is only for
containerized software.
And if you need things
like per machine licensing,
it can get a little
challenging and the like.
So that's where.
The quickie version--
I'm going to skip,
no, we'll do it--
of this.
So this is the overall
UI for Container Engine.
Because this is a talk, this
is kind of like a cooking show.
I've prepared the
cluster already.
It's already running.
And we click on this.
There's some information
about the cluster here,
but the main thing
I wanted to show you
is down here, instance groups.
It's actually using
the managed instance
groups of Compute Engine to
set the size of the pool.
So we're just using regular
Compute Engine features
to do that.
There is a dashboard built
into the open-source Kubernetes
tool.
It looks like this.
And I currently have
nothing deployed
behind this load balancer.
So there's a public
IP address here,
which I guess if it rewrites
quickly you could look at.
And there's nothing
running there right now.
So we can quickly say queue CTL
run, something named Engine X,
based off an image, a
Docker Image, Engine X.
And this is a web server
that's very commonly used.
And that's already deployed.
So if we take a look over
here, we actually already
have this thing called
a deployment, a pod.
I'm not going to go
into names too much,
but this pod is one
process, running Engine X.
And in fact, over
here in this window,
we're already seeing that
network connection actually
finished and we got the
default web serving page up.
We can also scale
and then say we
want to actually have,
say, 12 of these.
And by the time I get
back over here to refresh,
I didn't even catch it
with some of them starting.
They're actually all
running, up and going.
So that's a really quick
feel for Kubernetes.
So we talked about these things.
Basically, it's very
useful to insulate you
from your other infrastructure.
It enables higher utilization
so that the more processes you
have running, the higher
percentage of the CPU
you are using, the less money
you are spending overall.
And it is a really
nice abstraction spot
for many folks.
OK.
Next up is App Engine.
So App Engine is our
platform as a service.
It lets developers focus on
the code they're writing,
and then we handle the rest.
I think we could say it
was serverless early on.
So App Engine has been around
for six, seven years now--
actually, started
in 2008, so more.
And the trade-off App
Engine has always been,
if you write your app
in this particular way,
then give us the code and
we'll scale it up and down
from zero traffic to millions
of requests per second.
And we can make that happen.
Just recently, we've
announced and released
the App Engine
flexible environment,
which takes the good
stuff from App Engine
and lets you run any
Docker image and have
that managed by App Engine.
So you can take and run whatever
language you want to use,
any specific C
libraries you need--
these things that were
kind of limitations
in the previous
version of App Engine--
and you can run them.
And it also means
you can kind of
take advantage of the
containerization you've
been doing in other places.
So pretty much, if it runs
in a Docker container,
you can run it on
App Engine Flex.
When you're using App Engine,
you're thinking about the code
that you've written
in Python or Go--
whatever language you're using--
the HTTP requests and responses,
and the version of your code.
And that's about it.
There's no servers that
you need to worry about.
You can focus directly
on your business needs.
As I said before, it's
a really good fit.
It's meant for
serving websites--
websites, or HTTP APIs--
you know, anything
that's HTTP based.
Scales very well
to high traffic.
The standard version, we
have run times for several
languages, but you cannot add
your own binary extensions
to it.
And then the Flex version,
basically anything
you can do in Docker
you can do there.
Today, it's not the
best fit for sites
that go down to
almost no traffic
because Flex has a
minimum of two VMs.
So you end up paying for
two VMs under the covers
all the time, whereas standard
will scale down to zero and pay
nothing if there's no traffic.
So a quickie demo of App Engine.
So this is the App Engine
dashboard for a site
that I have that was made by
a colleague, Justin Beckwith,
and it serves up
an image of fruit.
It's the whole website.
But there are multiple
versions of this website
because some people
like different fruit.
And we've argued about
this a little bit.
We did some user
research to figure out
what the most popular fruit is.
Let's do some right now.
How many people
here like durian?
Actually, I'm not
even sure that's
an English word much
less translates over.
Let's go ahead and
switch the site
because we know durian
is a very popular fruit.
We're going to actually migrate
all the traffic from this site
to a new version
of the website that
serves up a different fruit.
And if I refresh the page,
does that look familiar?
What is that in French?
I didn't quite hear that,
but it's awesome maybe.
I think people love
or hate durian.
But we can switch the
version that quickly,
and you can roll back
to a previous version.
If we want to go back
to cherry because I
was wrong about
how popular it is,
we can revert back to a
previous version very easily.
And we can also kind
of split the traffic,
where we say we're going to
do 80% apple and 22% durian,
or whatever we'd like to do.
So that's a fun thing
you can do because you've
got the hosted environment.
OK.
So App Engine lets your
developers focus on code,
and we handle all the
rest that you need to do.
So that's awesome.
And if you add in the
flexible runtimes,
that means you can
run any Docker image
and you can also take that
image and run it other places.
So this same code that you've
made to run the App Engine,
you can run in Container
Engine or on virtual machines
or on your own
machines actually.
And even though this
is fully managed,
you can actually still SSH in
and do debugging and things
if you need to via Flex.
And just for fun, App
Engine is used a lot.
100 billion requests per
day on average last time we
updated the numbers.
So next up-- we're just
going to keep going--
Cloud Functions.
So this is internet
glue, I'm going to say.
And I think you can use it
in lots of different ways,
but I think one of the most
powerful, kind of easiest
places to start is for
things that are event driven.
Something happens.
You want to do some
processing, do something else.
So event, process.
Think of it as it just
starts a function call. .
So the events we
can trigger off of
are Pub/Sub, Cloud Storage,
and a straight HTTP request.
And this isn't actually
the topic of the talk,
but if you're using
Google Cloud I highly
recommend looking into
Pub/Sub and Cloud Storage.
They're kind of like the glue
between the blue hexagons.
Almost every application uses
Cloud Storage and Pub/Sub
in some fashion.
It's very, very useful.
So please check them out.
Cloud Functions
is fully managed.
You have the
function definition,
and you just push that
and we run it for you.
And you only pay per execution.
It is an open kind of format.
We have a Node.js
JS runtime that you
can run on your own
machines or you can
have hosted in Cloud Functions.
So you can do local testing
and run it in other places.
So when you're using
it, you're thinking
about events and the
function definition,
and that's kind of it.
It's a good fit when you want
to be serverless upfront.
If you're already using
Pub/Sub or Storage,
you don't want to think
about the runtime environment
very much.
And it's basically this glue.
Constraints wise,
I'll very carefully
say there is one runtime
today, and that's Node.js, so
JavaScript on Node.js.
Looking at other languages.
And it forces you to
think per function.
And sometimes, that's
a real advantage.
And sometimes, that
can get complicated
if you have lots of functions.
So kind of be careful there.
And demo is less of
a demo, more kind
of just what this looks like.
This is the Cloud
Functions overview here.
Let me actually go back.
So this is a list of different
functions I have deployed.
I've got a hello world function
that, as you might expect,
doesn't do very much.
It has an HTTP URL that
we can use to trigger it.
So if I click on that,
it will run it and do
whatever the function does.
We gave it no parameters.
And this function, if you
give it no parameters,
just says no message, I don't
know what to do with that.
So what does this
function look like?
We can come and look
at the source here.
And we'll find out that,
if there's no body,
it just returns this
message we just saw.
And if there is something,
it will actually
log that and return.
So it's kind of like
an echo hello world.
app.
So if I grab this, we can
actually come over here.
So you can do testing via
HTTP any way you like,
but there's also
kind of a built-in,
Let's just try this out tab.
So we can say, hello Paris.
Click Test the Function.
It will make that call.
We actually get a success back,
and that's what it looks like.
So there isn't that much
to see in Functions.
But basically, you
take some input.
You can do some work,
have a side effect or not,
and then return some
information back at the end.
So this is just a function
that lives in the cloud,
and you can use it to
connect different pieces.
It's integrated with our logging
system, centralized logging.
So you can look at it
here, but you can also
look at it in
Stackdriver Logging,
see what's happening with
them, that sort of thing.
OK.
So you think about Functions.
You don't have to
think about servers.
You just pay for what you use,
simple developer experience.
OK.
Seriously, where
should I run my code?
Did you find a good fit already?
So as I was talking
through things,
did Compute Engine or
Container Engine jump out?
If so, go take a look at that,
research that, play with that,
see what it looks like.
Probably, though, it
depends a little bit.
So here's a few more things that
you might consider in addition
to just what these tools are.
The level of abstraction
that it gives you,
the technical requirements
of your application,
and the team that you have--
your company, the
people you work with,
what those look like.
So for example, for
abstraction, what happens is,
what level do you want
to be thinking at?
So if you have people that are
more developer kind of mindset,
you might want to spend more
time thinking about code.
If you have a really
established operations group,
you may be already wanting to
think about containers or down
into Compute Engine.
So abstraction level.
Technical requirements.
So if you have specific
needs, if you need a custom
kernel to make your
application run,
you're probably
going to be looking
at VMs down at Compute Engine.
And so technical
constraints may kind of
push you down the
abstraction stack,
something that happens there.
And then your team.
How do they think
about software?
How comfortable are they
with containers, for example?
How much existing code
do you have that you
need to make sure it works?
And do you have
processes that need
to work a very specific
way in your company,
and you may need more
flexibility to implement those?
That may kind of push you
down into the details a bit
sometimes.
OK.
So all these
different things, how
do you make the right decision?
I'm going to claim, no worries.
It's actually very easy to
switch between these levels
if you're in containers.
So that's the kind of if there.
So if your application can
run in a Docker container,
then awesome.
And if you start at
the App Engine level--
so if you're starting a new
project and you start at a very
high level of abstraction--
if you want to move down,
it's a change one config line
and you go from App
Engine Standard to Flex.
Once you're in Flex, it
creates a Docker image
every time you deploy.
So you can take that
same Docker image
and you can run that
in Container Engine
or you can run that
in Compute Engine.
So you can take
the exact same code
and run it in all of these
environments already.
If you're starting at Compute
Engine and need to go up,
there's some work involved in
getting it into containers.
And then, you can
do the same thing.
You can kind of
move up the stack
and decide where
you want to run it.
Also, most systems
that are mature, they
end up using multiple
parts of things.
You might have an App Engine
frontend for your web API
and some long-running
processes--
maybe you do transcoding,
video transcoding,
or some other work--
in VMs.
So it's very common to have
a system that's made up
of using these together.
OK.
So back to the very
beginning, if you've
had an event-driven problem,
start at Cloud Functions.
If you are starting
a new thing, you
know you're going to be on the
web, start with App Engine.
If you're all in on containers,
Kubernetes, Container Engine.
And if you have an
existing system,
you should probably start
looking at Compute Engine.
And that is the core
of that, and I would
like to hand over to Elie.
And this clicker for you.
Thank h
[APPLAUSE]
ELIE MELOIS: Thank you.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
As you could understand,
I could have done
this presentation in French.
But I want Brian
to understand it,
so I will do it in
English as well.
So my name is Elie Melois.
I am one of the cofounders
and CTO of LumApps,
and I'm really glad
to be here today
to tell you more
about our journey
using Google Cloud Platform.
It's been more than
five years now.
So first, what is LumApps?
So LumApps is the only corporate
and social portal recommended
by Google, and it's fully
integrated with Google G Suite.
So it's basically everything
you need to work in one place.
And our goal is to make
sure that you will never
need your old intranet again.
So LumApps is a social,
mobile, and smart intranet
to connect and engage employees.
It brings all your
internal communication
in just a central hub--
so corporate news,
business applications
including G Suite, and
social collaboration.
It's built on top
of G Suite, and it
integrates as a
directory with Groups,
with Drive, with Gmail,
with Calendar, with Sites,
and much more.
And we are really proud at
LumApps to have a team 100%
dedicated to the
Google Cloud Platform.
And being a recommended
Google partner
means that we work, Google
and LumApps, together to align
all the product roadmaps.
And as you can see, our solution
has been adopted already
by major G Suite customers.
So for instance, Colgate,
Logitech, and Auchan
have recently joined
the LumApps family.
So just to give you a bit more
information about our story,
so we created the
company in 2012.
So at the beginning,
it was just three guys.
We were not in a garage
because in France people
work in an office.
And we started at a time
where the Google Cloud
Platform did not even exist.
So at that time, it
was called App Engine,
and it was a very,
very new product.
But when we started,
we didn't have
the necessary
financial resources
nor the time nor the people to
rely on our own infrastructure,
and we just wanted
to build our product.
And that's why we
chose App Engine, which
was at the time the only
fully-managed platform
available.
So we started the company
with a Java stack,
but we quickly moved to
Python because we loved
the simplicity of using it.
And we really like Google
technologies at LumApps,
so we adapted AngularJS
at the same time,
and we built an open-source
framework which is called LumX.
It's like material
designed for AngularJS.
It's open source, so
you should check it out.
And since then, more
and more companies
have been using our product.
Our team has been growing.
Our App Engine invoice also
has been growing bigger month
after month, but
that's good news.
And when Google recommended
us at the end of last year,
or whether it be customer like
Veolia with 50,000 employees
went live, we should
have been scared.
Would it work.
Will the platform run
under such a load?
The answer is yes.
And we like the most
boring Go life ever.
So we were just in
front of our computers,
looking at the platform
going to explode.
And no, it just works,
and you can go live
on a huge number of people
and the platform will work.
So as you can see,
we've been relying
on almost only the standard
App Engine from the beginning,
and we've been adding
some PCs along the way.
So our backend is in Python,
and we use all the niceties
from Google App Engine.
So we use the cache system.
We use the native integration
with Cloud Datastore,
which is NoSQL database.
And we use the queuing
system to handle large tasks
that you want to run
into in the background.
We also use Cloud Endpoints,
which is a framework
to build some API.
So you have all the OS/2
authentication built in.
It's the same technology that
runs the API on all the Google
products, so Drive, Gmail,
Calendar, and so on.
And it's used by all our clients
through the web, Android, iOS,
and all our customers who are
doing some custom integration
using the API.
So my diagram here is
not totally accurate
because we have some PCs
running outside of App Engine.
So for instance, we have a
small cluster of Elasticsearch.
I will explain after
a while we have this.
And we also have some
machine learning PCs which
are running on Compute Engine.
And with this, we can interact
with external services--
so that can be all the Drive
API, Calendar API, Gmail API,
as well as other third parties.
We also plan on
integrating with Firebase
for real-time notification
and directions in the product.
So you can do pretty much
everything with App Engine,
but sometimes when you use
it you will get a roadblock.
And you have to
ask this question,
should I move away
from App Engine,
should I go down the stack to
Container Engine or Compute
Engine?
Well this happened to
us at various occasions,
and we always add to come
up with a pragmatic solution
to handle these situations.
So let me tell you the
story of our search engine,
for instance.
So it's to build on top of
the App Engine Search API
and some third party's API.
So the App Engine Search
API is really great.
It allows you to index
documents and do complex queries
at scale.
It's fully managed.
And don't get me
wrong, it just works.
So for us, it was like
the perfect search system.
So we started using it in
production back in 2012,
and at this time it was
like an alpha product.
So it was very, very new.
But it has always worked
for us except when
you do some very complex queries
which exceed 2,000 bytes.
And when you do that,
it just doesn't work.
And so this is the limit.
But we needed more because we
have some very complex queries
to run, but this is a very
small fraction of our queries.
So the question was, should
we remove the Search API
for those queries?
And the answer was no.
We will just create a
small Elasticsearch cluster
and index the documents twice.
And for the small
fraction of queries
that do not work
with the Search API,
we will use the Elasticsearch
cluster instead.
And this cluster runs
on Compute Engine.
And it's the same with the API.
So the Cloud Endpoints
framework is really great
to expose your API and
have a way for people
to interact with it online.
But it doesn't come with a
good documentation system yet,
so we had to hack our way
into creating such a portal.
But as the framework for Cloud
Endpoints is open source,
we were able to just
create this portal using
these open-source libraries.
And so just a few
tips if you want
to be using App
Engine efficiently.
The first thing is that
you should read the manual.
There are some very good
stuff in the documentation
from Google, especially
the English version,
which is more up to date.
You shouldn't be afraid to use
services that are relatively
new because they work.
So we used some service in
alpha mode, and it was just OK.
You should subscribe to the
mailing list from App Engine
because there is some
really good stuff here,
and you can get some
good information.
And the last point
is not obvious,
but you should pay for
support because sometimes when
you are in production you
really have some issues
and you want the support
team to give you some answers
very quickly.
So everything is
great with App Engine,
but we have a few
challenges today.
So the first one is about
measuring and debugging.
So App Engine comes
with Stackdriver,
which are a lot of features
to do some logging,
some analytics on the
code, some debugging.
So it's really great.
It's really good to have access
to all the logging system
and to be able to
search inside the logs.
But sometimes, you need more.
You need to have an agent
installed on the machine,
and you cannot
this with standard.
So for instance,
if you want to use
a tool like [INAUDIBLE]
or Duck Duck Duck,
you won't be able to do it
with Google App Engine standard
and you will have
to move to Flex.
Then we have some, I
wouldn't say issues,
but sometimes it can
be tricky to have
your application working in some
countries, especially in China
where App Engine is not the best
tool over in these countries.
You have some quotas also.
So for instance, if you intend
to send a very large number
of emails, you will be
limited on App Engine
because they want to
prevent spam and so on.
So keep in mind those quotas.
And if you need more,
you should consider
using an Excel service instead.
For the database, you
have Cloud Datastore,
which is really good tool, but
you need to know how to use it.
Because, if you use
it as a SQL database,
it will just not work.
So keep in mind that
it's designed for scale
and that there is
some trade-off when
you design your data model.
And if you do that,
you can really
have something which
will scale with no limit.
And the last point is about
moving from standard to Flex.
So as Brian was
saying, if you want
to move from one to
another, you need
to really decouple
the services that you
are using because
natively on standard you
can use the cache
system, the queue system,
and the Datastore.
And you cannot do this directly
using the same libraries
on Flex .
So there are some
trade-offs on how you
can move from one to the other.
And finally, let's talk
about the new stuff
that we are working on.
So the first one
is Cloud Spanner,
and this one is really exciting.
It offers the scalability
of a managed database
but with the flexibility of SQL.
So we will implement it for
complex objects, relationships
where the Cloud Datastore is
maybe too limited for this--
it's not the right tool.
We also want to implement a
multiregion infrastructure
because we have instances in
multiple regions in App Engine.
And natively, there
is no load balancer
on top of all these regions, so
you have to do it on your own.
And so we are looking
at the best way
to aggregate all
of the instances
under the same infrastructure.
And finally, so our
dream at LumApps
is to build a personal
assistant for employees
and to be proactive to
serve the right information
to the right people
at the right time.
And to do that, we've started
implementing machine learning
algorithms, and we want
to intensify the usage
and build on top of Cloud
ML to scale our models
and refine our data.
And so, finally, when I
prepared for this presentation,
Brian asked me a question.
He said, if you had to
make the decision today,
would you make
the same decision?
And the answer is yes.
App Engine has been really
helpful along the way.
And frankly, I'm not sure
I would be here today
if we had not made this
choice five years ago.
So today, we have 1.5 million
users with only one person
doing some DevOps in the team.
So we were able to
really focus on building
the product, which is great.
What we could have
done better is
the decoupling between
standard App Engine features
to make sure that it's
easy to switch from one
system to another, so from
standard to flex to contain
Container Engine and
to Compute Engine.
That's all.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
as